This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持身体健康以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO点，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人身披铠甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I talk through some of the big changes and transition of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hi, how are we all? are we managing, struggling, coping? Let's start with a little check-in moment because times are kind of depressing right now and very isolating being in lockdown as I'm fairly sure most of us are at the moment. So how are you feeling?
大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个非常不专业的播客，在这里我将和大家聊聊我们在20岁时经历的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。嗨，大家最近都怎么样？你们是在勉强支撑、苦苦挣扎，还是在应付过去？让我们先做一个简短的近况检查，因为现在这个时期多少有点令人沮丧，而且就像我相当确定我们大多数人目前所经历的那样，处于封锁状态会让人感到非常孤立。所以你们现在感觉怎么样？
Really, though, how are you feeling? What's your body telling you you need right now? Maybe it's a nap, some social connection, in a case of beers, maybe something creative, some water. Actually, that's something I've realized being in lockdown. I do not drink like any water. None.
说真的，你们感觉怎么样？你的身体现在在告诉你它需要什么？也许是一个小憩，一些社交互动，几箱啤酒，也许是一些有创意的事情，一些水。事实上，这是我在封锁期间意识到的事情。我几乎不喝水。一点都不喝。
Because now I'm not at the office and using the kitchen. There's like an excuse to get up every 10 minutes. But yeah, in all seriousness. Pause this episode for a bit. I promise it's not that good. Just do a little check in with your body. Go get some water. Go.
因为现在我不在办公室，也不去茶水间。这就少了一个每10分钟就站起来一次的借口。不过说真的，暂停这个节目一会儿。我保证它没那么好。只是给你的身体做个小小的检查。去弄点水喝。去吧。
Drink some water. Give your body what she wants. Are we all back now, hydrated, happier? Good. Let's get into it. I really didn't know what to record this week. I had a bunch of episodes planned around internalized misogyny, friendship breakups, which I put on my Instagram story, dating apps, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. It all just seemed a little bit trivial. And there are also episodes I want to give a bit more thought. and research into and I kind of hit the lockdown depression wall pretty hard these past three days so let's be honest I'm not really up for researching like a 30 minute episode on like friendship
喝点水。满足你身体的需求。大家都回来了吗，补充了水分，开心了吗？很好。我们开始吧。我真的不知道这周该录制什么。我原本计划了一堆关于内化厌女症、友情破裂（我把它发到了我的Instagram快拍上）、约会软件等等的节目，诸如此类。这一切看起来都有点微不足道。而且这些也是我想花更多心思去思考和研究的节目。过去三天里，我差不多结结实实地撞上了封锁期抑郁之墙，所以说实话，我真的没有心情去研究诸如友情破裂这样长达30分钟的节目。
breakups right now I feel like that would just be a little bit too much so sorry to disappoint but I'm sure a few of you are in the same boat for Canberra it's been about three weeks since I last got to hug my beautiful friends and exist beyond this pattern of work and uni, walks around the neighborhood, half a bottle of wine at the end of the night. And I just miss humans being messy and attractive and weird and funny. And Zoom just does not do people justice, especially the beautiful people in my life. You know, their souls are just, they're too big for Zoom. They're too big.
现在我觉得那可能有点太难为人了，所以很抱歉让大家失望了，但我确信你们当中也有不少人处境相同。对堪培拉来说，距离我上次拥抱我美丽的朋友们，并且在工作和大学、社区散步、夜晚结束时喝上半瓶酒的这种生活模式之外喘口气，已经大约有三 weeks（三周）了。我只是想念那些真实、迷人、怪异且有趣的活生生的人。而Zoom根本无法展现出人们的风采，尤其是那些我生命中美丽的人们。你知道，他们的灵魂实在是太大了，Zoom容纳不下。它们太大了。
So I thought for this week we could actually address, you know, a very current moment in time topic. Let's talk about lockdown and the psychology behind why lockdowns have such a profound influence on our mental health. As much as it sucks, I do feel very lucky compared to those who live alone. At least I have people around me, which is really lovely. But my housemates do not give me nearly enough hugs because their love language is not physical affection, but mine is. So, Oscar, Ariana, if you're listening, please don't let me. wilt up and die alone in my room watching mind hunters. Please give me a hug. I need it at this point. But this is a shorter episode because I really just wanted to talk about some mental health tips for
所以我认为本周我们可以讨论一个非常贴合当下时代的议题。我们来聊聊封锁，以及封锁为什么会对我们的心理健康产生如此深远影响背后的心理学。尽管这很糟糕，但与那些独居的人相比，我确实觉得自己非常幸运。至少我身边有人，这真的很可爱。但我的室友给我的拥抱远远不够，因为他们的爱的语言不是身体接触，而我的却是。所以，奥斯卡、阿里安娜，如果你们在听的话，请不要让我在房间里一边看着《心理神探》一边枯萎死去。请给我一个拥抱。我这会儿真的需要它。不过这是一期较短的节目，因为我真的很想聊聊一些关于封锁期间的心理健康小贴士，
lockdown, going a little bit deeper than self-care and just have a little chat while we examine how to reconnect with yourself in a time that feels really disconnected. I'm also just really fucking tired. So maybe the length of this episode can serve as a lesson that it's important to give us you know, a little bit of space and be extra patient around what we're capable of doing during these times. So I read this excellent article recently on the impact of lockdown on our mental health and I think it really sums up the thought and emotional patterns I'm sure hips of us are going through. So essentially COVID lockdowns are the world's biggest and most profound psychological experiment like ever. So since COVID emerged, 5.5 billion people have entered some form of lockdown.
比自我关爱稍微深入一点，并在我们探讨如何在感觉严重与世隔绝的时期重新与自己建立联系时，做一次小小的闲聊。而且我也真的累透了。所以这期节目的时长也许可以作为一个教训，告诉我们留出一点空间，并对我们在这些时期能够做的事情保持格外的耐心是多么重要。因此，我最近读了这篇极好的文章，关于封锁对我们心理健康的影响，我认为它真的概括了我们当中许多人肯定正在经历的思想和情感模式。所以本质上，新冠封锁是有史以来世界上最大、最深刻的心理学实验。因此，自从新冠出现以来，已有55亿人进入了某种形式的封锁状态。
And we already have all these studies and papers being released about the impacts on people mentally and emotionally. And in short, perhaps unsurprisingly, people who are quarantined, you're very likely to develop a wide range of symptoms of just psychological stress. Low mood, insomnia, stress, irritability. emotional exhaustion, depression as well. And even post-traumatic stress symptoms, yeah, but low mood and irritability specifically. They stand out as being super common was one study that I was reading said.
我们已经有所有这些关于对人们心理和情感影响的研究和论文发表。简而言之，也许并不令人意外，处于隔离状态的人们非常有可能出现各种心理压力的症状。情绪低落、失眠、压力、易怒、情感精疲力竭，还有抑郁。甚至还有创伤后应激症状，是的，但是情绪低落和易怒尤为突出。它们作为超级常见的问题脱颖而出，我读过的一项研究如是说。
And I think reasons for stress are just so abound in lockdown. There's risk of infection, there's a fear of becoming sick or of losing loved ones, financial hardship, being isolated from people. and all of these many more as well, they're present in this current pandemic. And I think what will be really interesting to see is the long-term effects of this psychologically, especially perhaps even some form of generational trauma could kind of come out of this, because it is something that very few generations have experienced to this magnitude. And I'm not at all saying that this is any sort of argument against lockdowns because I'm not an idiot.
我认为封锁中产生压力的原因实在是数不胜数。存在感染风险，对生病或失去挚爱的恐惧，经济困难，与世隔绝，以及所有这些更多的因素，都存在于当前的这场大流行中。我认为真正有趣的是看到这一切在心理上产生的长期影响，甚至可能某种形式的代际创伤也会从中产生，因为这是极少数代我经历过如此规模的事情。我绝不是说这是任何反对封锁的论据，因为我不是个白痴。
But I do think that context is important to be able to understand what we can do individually at the moment to keep ourselves same. So trauma psychologists have broken down a typical pattern of response or individual phases in response to a disaster or something unexpected, like a lockdown. And these stages, most people move through them when confronted with something that kind of alters the norm. So here's the thing. Even if it's your second, third, seventh lockdown, these phases are still pretty much the same,
但我确实认为，了解背景对于理解我们目前可以做些什么来保持精神正常是很重要的。因此，创伤心理学家总结了面对灾难或诸如封锁这般意料之外的事情时，典型的反应模式或个人阶段。这些阶段，大多数人在面对某种改变了常态的事情时都会经历。所以情况是这样的。即使这是你的第二次、第三次、第七次封锁，这些阶段也基本上是一样的，
even with fatigue and formative learning due to the experience of previous lockdowns. So this model that research has proposed. So when we first lockdown, when it first begins, we have this initial adaptational response. We might feel hyper-focused and prepared. However, as time kind of progresses, the impact is finally really delivered, which is often accompanied by that peak in stress, angst, panic. I'm sure we've all been there. And this is when we are really confronted with essentially the reality of the situation.
即使由于先前封锁的经历而带有疲劳感和形成性学习。所以这就是研究人员提出的模型。因此，当我们第一次封锁，也就是它刚开始的时候，我们会有这种最初的适应性反应。我们可能会感到高度专注和有所准备。然而，随着时间的推移，这种冲击最终真正降临了，这通常伴随着压力、焦虑、恐慌的峰值。我确信我们都经历过这种情况。这就是我们真正面对局面的现实的时候。
But luckily, as the days go by, we soon enter this like honeymoon phase, is what the researchers call it, where we feel almost more comfortable in this situation. We feel we can anticipate what's coming next. We feel more settled. Perhaps we even feel happier with thinking about all the things that we wanted to do that we can now do in lockdown. Maybe you're doing heaps of baking, heaps of drinking, whatever it is. almost like it's a bit of a blessing but we do drop off back from there and at one point we'll just hit like an equilibrium where it feels that nothing's changed we kind of do get that sense
但幸运的是，随着日子一天天过去，我们很快就会进入研究人员所说的“蜜月期”，在这个阶段，我们对这种情况感到更加舒适。我们觉得我们可以预料接下来会发生什么。我们感觉更加安定。也许我们甚至会觉得更高兴，因为我们想到了所有那些我们以前想做但现在可以在封锁期间做的事情。也许你在做大量的烘焙，大量的喝酒，不管是什么。几乎就像是一种福气，但我们确实会从那里回落，在某个时刻，我们会达到一种平衡状态，感觉没有什么改变，我们确实有一种舒适感，但随着我们的焦虑消退，适应性反应减弱，我们确实经历了日益增长的幻灭感或麻木感。所以这种感觉随着时间的推移而增加，虽然我们可能看起来（你知道）融入了社区，并且个人对这些情况进行了适应。随着时间的流逝，随着我们经历更多独自一人或处于隔离状态的周数，事情发生了变化，人们经历了一场心理转变，从震惊和行动转变为静止，但也伴随着空虚。这就是（你知道）对许多人来说，我确信，封锁的感觉，这种从压力到狂喜，再到静止、麻木、停滞的过山车，尤其是当新鲜感消退时。而且，（你知道）对于许多人来说，现实也随之袭来。因此，有一种观点认为，对于个人的内心而言，封锁或隔离包括六个阶段。所以第一阶段，我们有最初的行动和规划，当时它刚刚宣布，你正在考虑你需要购买的所有杂货，你正在考虑你需要整理的所有事情。这有点像生存模式，我们觉得我们必须为这个巨大的变化做好一切准备。然后我们进入第二阶段，这有点像保持冷静，继续前行，让我们度过这个难关，
of comfort but as our anxiety declines and that adaptational response drops off we do experience a growing disillusionment or numbness so this increases with time and although we may seem you know engaged community and an individual adaptation to this circumstances. As time does pass as we go through more weeks of being by ourselves or being in quarantine, things shift and people undergo a psychological transformation away from shock and action to a stillness, but also an emptiness as well. This is for what, you know, for many, I'm sure, what lockdown kind of feels like, this roller coaster of stress to elation, to stillness, numbness, stagnation, especially as the novelty wears off. And, you know, for many, and, you know,
有很多未知数，然后是第三阶段。所以第三阶段有点像这些创伤心理学家所想的蜜月期。所以这是一种狂喜感，通常与一种狂热的生产力有关，你知道，你只是把自己投入到新的项目中，把自己投入到大学和工作中，大量地锻炼。然后我们进入第四阶段，也就是我刚才谈到的瘫痪和焦虑。然后是第五阶段，也就是放慢脚步，有点进入状态，你知道，你已经有时间适应这个了，你觉得你有点能够理解正在发生的事情。然后我们有第六阶段，我确信我们很多人现在都处于这个阶段，这就是麻木和
and reality kind of sinks in. So there's this idea that a lockdown or quarantine consists of six stages for someone internally. So stage one, we've got that initial action and planning where it's just been announced and you're thinking about all the groceries you need to buy, you're thinking about all the things that you need to organize. And it's kind of like the survival mode where we're like, we have to get everything ready for this big change. And then we hit stage two and it's kind of keep calm, carry on, let's just get through
那种新的常态。就像有些人称之为“土豆模式”，就是无聊、停滞，好像什么都没有发生。而职业倦怠也是其中的一个非常大的部分。所以，是的，我绝对能感同身受。现在，我觉得我在第六阶段和第四阶段之间切换，特别是目前处于第六阶段。我最近感到非常精疲力竭。我不知道有多少其他人也有这种感觉，但我就是完全无法让自己有任何动力。我只觉得真的很累，然后定期从我的书桌移动到我的床，到我的手机，到我的厨房，你知道，再去泡一杯绿茶，我有点希望它能同时让我平静下来并给我动力。所以我只是，
this. a lot of unknowns, and then stage three. So stage three is kind of like that honeymoon phase that these trauma psychologists thought of. So it's a sense of elation, often associated with like a productivity frenzy, you know, you're just throwing yourself into new projects, throwing yourself into uni and work, exercising heaps. And then we hit stage four, which is that paralysis and anxiety I was talking about. And then stage five, so slowing down, kind of getting into the groove of it, you know, you've had time to adjust to this, you feel that you kind of are capable of understanding what's going. And then we have stage six, which I'm sure a lot of us are in now, which is just numbness and
对目前的生存意义有点困惑，但读到这其实是我们面对封锁或灾难之类的事情时往往会经历的正常模式，这真的很有用。在这段时期，职业倦怠是一个需要大加注意的事情，特别是在经历了高度焦虑和适应新常态的时期之后，从去酒吧、见人、进行各项活动中获得刺激感中抽离出来。这是一个艰难的调整，它确实给我们的应对机制和神经系统带来了很大的压力。所以职业倦怠，就像我说的，在这段时间里真的是需要注意的事情，并确保你经常审视自己的状态。它通常表现为精神疲惫、
the new kind of normal. Like some people call it like a lump mode, just like boredom, stagnation, kind of not having anything going on. And burnout is also a really big part of this as well. So yeah, I can definitely relate to this. Right now, I think I kind of switch between stage six and stage four, especially stage six at the moment. I have felt so burnt out recently. I'm not sure how many other people have felt this way, but I just like cannot motivate myself at all. I just feel really tired and just move periodically from my desk to my bed, to my phone, to my kitchen, you know, for another cup of green tea that I'm kind of hoping will simultaneously calm me down and motivate me. So I'm just,
非常易怒、注意力下降、冷漠以及对成就感满意度的降低。它也会使事情更难完成，这我在自己身上最近看到了很多，而我感觉到的导致职业倦怠的一个巨大促成因素至少是这种个人生活与家庭生活、休闲放松空间以及工作和大学生活之间缺乏区别。工作和那些我只是在放松、做我的爱好或其他事情的时间之间根本没有隔离。你拥有的只是你的家允许你创造的空间，而你的工作生活（尤其是居家办公）与你的社交生活或放松时间之间必要的隔离，在你20岁时真的很难，尤其是当我们住在
a bit confused by the point of existing at the moment, but it was really useful to kind of read that this is a normal pattern that we tend to go through when we're confronted with something like a lockdown or like a disaster. And a burnout is a big thing to watch out for this in this time, especially after that period of heightened anxiety and adapting to a new normal, moving away from getting stimulation from going out to bars and seeing people and having activities to do. It's a hard adjustment and it does place a lot of pressure on our coping mechanisms and our nervous system as well. So burnout, it's like I said, really something to look out for in this time and make sure you're checking in with yourself. It often looks like mental exhaustion,
与室友合租的小房子或公寓里。这真的他妈的很难。所以我发现自己把房间用于所有事情，这首先使得关掉工作状态变得非常困难，但同时当我必须做与工作相关的任务或完成事情时，进入工作状态也变得非常困难。就像我说的，生产力绝对来了一个急转直下，然而我读到的一篇关于这方面的非常有趣的研究论文，提供了一些很好的建议，可以在你无法创造物理上截然不同的地方或去任何地方（比如办公室或图书馆）时，在你的脑海中为不同的活动创造区别。基本上，我读到的这篇论文中的研究人员建议你做的是，在你的房子或生活空间周围创建不同的工作站，
really irritable, reduce concentration, detachment and decrease satisfaction with your accomplishments. It can also make it harder to get things done, which I've been seeing a lot within myself at the moment and a big contributing factor to burnout I've been feeling at least is this lack of distinction between my personal and my home life, my leisure, relaxing space and then work and uni as well. There is just no separation between work and the times when I'm just relaxing or doing my hobbies or other things. You only have the space your home allows you to kind of create and that necessary separation of your work life, especially working from home and your socializing life or your relaxation time, it's really hard in your 20s, especially when we live
这些工作站独特地与你日常进行的某一项任务或活动相关联，例如，你的书桌是用来做大学作业的，而且只能做大学作业；餐桌是用来做带薪工作的；我想你的床是用来休息的，沙发是用来看电视的，你不能在你与另一项任务相关联的工作站里做任何其他任务，否则宇宙就会爆炸。这就是教训。你必须把它们区分开来。这是一种分隔你空间的绝佳方法。它非常有利于提高生产力，并为你的日常带来某种常规和细微差别。我确实尝试过这个。它确实在一段时间内很有帮助，但后来外面变得阴雨寒冷，
in small sharehouses or apartments with roommates. It's just really fucking hard. So I'll find myself using my room for everything, which makes it really hard to switch off firstly, but also really hard to switch on when I have to do tasks or accomplish things that are work-related. Like I said, productivity has definitely taken a huge nose dive, but a really interesting research paper. I read on this, however, offered some really good suggestions for creating distinction between different activities in your mind whilst you are unable to create physically distinct places or go anywhere. So like the office or the library. Essentially, the researchers in this paper I read suggested you do is create like different stations around
你知道有时你只是想在床上看网课，但如果你有空间和纪律，我绝对推荐这样做，有证据表明这确实有助于创建这些小工作站，我确信我们以前都听说过这一点，但围绕你的日子建立结构、日常仪式、一个特定的起床时间（那个真的很关键）、你锻炼的时间、你吃饭和上睡觉的时间，这对于恢复正常状态和让你的大脑摆脱其他正在发生的事情真的很有帮助。我知道这比我们想象的要难得多，因为没有什么其他东西强加给你一个结构，但我想最终封锁会结束，你必须能够回到日常生活中，
your house or your living space that are uniquely associated with one task or activity that you do on a daily basis so for example your desk is for uni work and uniwork only the dining table is for paid work I guess your bed is for rest and the couch is for TV and you cannot do any other task in the station that you've associated with one other, or the universe just explodes. That's the lesson. You have to keep them distinct. And this is a really good method separating your space. It's really good for increasing productivity and giving some form of routine and nuance to the hours in your day. And I did try this. It did really help for a while, but then it got really rainy and cold
所以尽你所能保持尽可能多的这些习惯从长远来看真的很有帮助。我真正坚持的另一件事是规划愉悦的活动。所以这是一种通常用于管理抑郁的行为策略。它被称为愉悦活动规划，它确实有助于提升你的情绪，尤其是在很难找到事情去规划或者你知道没有什么值得期待的时期，因为事情太不确定了。基本上，正如你所能猜到的，它包括定期在不同的时间间隔规划你喜欢的事情。你知道，周一，我跟朋友视频；周二，我点外卖；周三，
outside and you know sometimes you just want to watch your lectures in bed but if you have the space and the discipline I would definitely recommend there is evidence behind this really helping creating those little stations and I'm sure we've all heard this before but creating structure around your days daily rituals a specific wake-up time that one's really crucial a time when you exercise when you eat your meals and go to bed it's really helpful for a staff normalcy and getting your mind off of what else is going on and I know it's a lot harder than we make it out to be because there is nothing else kind of enforcing a structure upon you but I think eventually a lockdown ends and you've got to be able to move back into everyday
我画点画或类似的事情。这是一种行为激活的形式，它允许你通过在预定时间给你打气来让你感觉对自己的情绪更有掌控力，从而保持你的幸福感很高，我们非常喜欢这样。我们很乐意看到这一点。我认为封锁和一般隔离的另一个非常难的部分是，很少有什么东西可以取代人际连接。老实说。我花了很多时间看RSPCA（皇家防止虐待动物协会）的网站，心想现在是领养一只猫的好时机。这是一个妄想的想法。我不需要领养一只猫，但这确实表明我们需要某种对其他生物的刺激或连接。当我们被剥夺了人际交往时，我们的大脑实际上会失去白质。
life so trying to keep up as many of those habits as you can is really helpful in the long term the other thing I really stand by is planning pleasurable activities So this is a behavioral strategy that's often used for managing depression. So it's called pleasant activity scheduling and it really helps boost your mood, especially at times when it's really difficult to find things to plan for or to, you know, there's not much to look forward to because things are just so uncertain. Essentially, as I'm sure you can guess, it involves periodically planning things that you enjoy at different intervals. So you know, on Monday, I assume my friends on Tuesday I order Uber Eats on Wednesday.
例如，在实验室动物中，我记得这是你在许多心理学课程中都会学到的一个非常常见的études（研究）。基本上，实验人员隔离了实验大鼠或实验动物。事实证明，这种隔离会导致大脑萎缩，并可能导致这些动物患阿尔茨海默病的风险增加。因此，我们必须保持这些社会联系。不断伸出援手，不断尝试做事。如果你感到缺乏触觉或连接，这听觉起来有点悲伤，但我发现的一个非常好的策略是双手紧握，闭上眼睛。这是一种经证实的模仿人类触觉的心理学方法。而且，你知道，有时一个女孩不得不这么做。你知道，我想握着别人的手。那不妨
day, I paint something or something along those lines. And it's a form of behavioral activation that allows you to feel more in control of your mood by giving you a pick-me-up at scheduled times to keep your happiness high, which we do love. We love to see that. I think another really hard part of lockdowns and quarantine in general is that there is very little that can replace human connection. I will be honest. I have spent a large amount of time looking at the RSPCA website thinking this would be a great time to adopt a cat. That is a delusional thought. I do not need to adopt a cat, but it does show that we do need some form of simulation or connection to other living creatures. When we're deprived of human interactions, our brain literally loses white matter.
握我自己的手。我们确实听过那些基本的策略，比如给朋友打电话，主动联系，但有时我们真正需要的是人类的触觉。一个温暖的热水澡也非常有用。跳舞也一样，它让我们能够以一种我们经常在人类性行为中寻找的方式与自己的身体感觉更加连接。所以跳舞，感受你身体的运动，感觉与你的四肢的连接，是感觉依附于物理当下和你的物理形态的一种绝佳方式。最后，如果你感到超级压力或恐慌，正如在这个时期非常可以理解的那样，当你独自一人且无法真正向他人求助时，你可以做一些非常有用事情。首先，我很久以前听过这个小贴士，但吃一顿饭或吃点东西。
In lab animals, for example, I remember this is a really common study that you learn about in many psychology courses. Basically, experimenters, they isolate lab rats or lab animals. And that isolation is shown to cause brain shrinkage and it can lead to an increased risk of Alzheimer's disease in these animals. So it's imperative that we keep up those social ties. Keep reaching out, keep trying to do things. And if you are feeling deprived of touch or connection, this is kind of sad, but a really good strategy I've found is to clasp. It's your hands together and close your eyes. It is a proven psychological method for imitating human touch. And, you know, sometimes a girl has to do it. You know, I want to hold someone's hand. It may as well
所以进食有助于平静神经系统，因为它实际上激活了我们的消化系统，这是我们的大脑在恐慌时刻关闭的第一批系统之一。因此，基本上通过进食并在胃里放点东西，你是在向你的神经系统传递这样一个信息：你知道，如果我们有压力，我们就不会进食。如果我们处于危险之中，你知道，我们就不会吃杏仁当零食，因为我们会逃跑。所以它通过利用这种生物反馈的形式来欺骗大脑平静下来，在这种形式中，你能够通过告诉你的身体真的没有什么好担还有的来控制这些生物学的逃跑或战斗机制。
be my own. And we do hear those basic strategies of, you know, calling a friend, reaching out, but sometimes it is human touch that we really do need. And a warm shower is also really useful. Dancing as well, it allows us to feel more connected with our bodies in a way that we so often look to human your sex for. So dancing, feeling like the movement in your body, feeling connected to your limbs, it's a really great way to feel attached to the physical present and in your physical form. Finally, if you're feeling super stressed or panicky, as is so understandable at this time, there are some really helpful things that you can do when you're alone and you can't really reach out to others. Firstly, I heard this tip ages ago, but eat a meal or eat something.
还有一些更基础的例子。我确信你可以在互联网上查到这些，但如果你在听，也许这会有所帮助。所以呼吸练习，剧烈运动，或者最后在你的手腕上放一些真的很冷的东西或去外面的寒冷中，这有助于让你冷静下来，但它也将血液重新引导回你的大脑和心脏，让你更加集中精神。好吧，就像我说的，这期节目到处都是。
So eating helps calm the nervous system because it actually. activates our digestive system, which is one of the first systems our brain shuts down in moments of panic. So essentially by eating and putting something in your stomach, you're communicating with your nervous system this message that, you know, if we were stressed, we wouldn't be eating. And if we're in danger, you know, we wouldn't be snacking on almonds because we'd be fleeing. So it tricks the brain into calming down by kind of it using this form of biofeedback, where you're able to control these biological flight or fight mechanisms, but telling your body there's really nothing to worry about.
这只是一种策略的过山车，但我认为我们太多次发现自己在大谈特谈自我关爱，这很好，你知道，当然。自我关爱被吹捧为这种巨大的心理健康解药，但它真的不是一个完整的解决方案。你知道，敷个面膜很好。很好，但它并不能真正平息经历一场大流行的心理创伤。
And just some more basic examples. I'm sure you can look these up on the internet, but if you're listening, maybe this is helpful. So breathing exercises, vigorous exercise, or finally putting something really cold on your wrists or going outside in the cold, this helps cool you down, but it also diverts blood back into your brain and back into your heart and centralises you a bit more. Okay, like I said, this episode is all over the place.
你知道，我不知道有哪家公司能为此制造出足够好的面膜。但是更大习惯和策略，确实需要建立起来。所以希望这有点用。这只是我一直在学习的，我一直在自己身上看到的。我也觉得这就像是一个我需要的总结，就像是，是的，一个提醒。我们可以度过这个难关。你知道，我们的大脑并不是我们任由其摆布的东西。
This was just kind of a roller coaster of strategies, but I think we way too often find ourselves talking about self-care, which is great, you know, sure. Self-care is kind of lauded as this huge mental health antidote, but it's really not a full solution. You know, doing a face mask is great. It's nice, but it's not really going to quell the psychological trauma of going through a pandemic.
我们可以控制我们的身体对压力情境的反应。这是一个非常糟糕的时期。一直在看很多《心理神探》，这并没有什么帮助，但这是一部非常棒的剧。如果你想在网飞（Netflix）的观看清单上添加点什么的话，我还在做什么？在IGA（超市）花了很多钱，只是买一些乱七八糟的东西，比如巧克力慕斯和寿司。不太确定这些有多必要。但我想，你吃同一款优膳食品（Hello Fresh）的次数真的是有限的，在你对鸡肉、土豆和莳萝蛋黄酱感到厌烦之前。
You know, I don't know any company that makes a good enough face mask for that. But bigger habits and strategies, they do need to be established. So hopefully this is somewhat useful. This is just kind of what I've been learning, what I've been seeing in myself. I also just feel like this was kind of like a run-down that I needed to be like, yes, a reminder. We can get through this. You know, our brain is something that we're not at the whims of.
如果你吃过优膳食品，你就知道我在说什么。那个他妈的莳萝蛋黄酱，你知道的，你知道我在说什么。但我们会度过难关的，我非常不坚定地说。我们可以度过难关。老实说，祝你们所有人好运。这个播客对我来说真是一根救命稻草。所以谢谢你们所有的支持和爱，我也加倍奉还。看，你能听到外面在下雨，因为我是在车里录音的，多好啊，雨
We can control how our body reacts to stressful situations. And this is a really shitty time. Been watching a lot of mine hunters, which hasn't really helped, but is a really good show. If you want to add something onto the watch list on Netflix, what else have I been doing? Spending a lot of money at the IGA, just buying, like, done stuff, like chocolate mousse and sushi. Not really sure how essential those are. but there's really only so many times you can eat the same hello fresh meals, I think, before you get kind of tired of like chicken and potatoes and dill mayo.
下下来了，也许去睡个午觉，这非常平静，是的，保持新冠安全，照顾好自己。我保证下周我会有一期更有趣的节目，而不是只有我唠叨着自我关爱和应对策略，我确信我们都知道这些，但如果你觉得它有用，是的，这就是唯一的事情，而且我觉得它对我自己很有用，所以照顾好自己，保持新冠安全，与朋友联系，外面有那么多的爱，我下周会带着一期我向你们保证会更精彩的节目回来。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析
And if you have hello fresh, you know what I'm talking about. The fucking dill mayo, you know, you know what I'm talking about. But we will get through this, I say very unconvincingly. We can get through this. And in all honesty, I'm wishing you all, godspeed. This podcast has been such a lifeline for me. So thanks for all the support and love, and I'm giving it right back. and look you can hear it raining because I'm recording this in my car how nice good that the rain's
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持身体健康以及建立抗压能力。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO点，可在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。
coming out might go have a nap it's very calming and yeah stay COVID safe take care of yourselves I promise next week I will have a more interesting episode rather than just me rambling about self-care and coping strategies that I'm sure we all know but if you found it useful yeah that's the only thing and I found it useful for myself so take care of yourself stay COVID safe, connect with friends, there's so much love out there, and I'll be back next week with an episode that is, I promise you, a bit more exciting. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, or fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me.
84年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人身披铠甲？这向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。请在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个IHart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
84年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他获取播客的平台上收听回顾节目。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专注于黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方往往并不安全，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，就非得这么做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他获取播客的平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。